wait how do you how'd you break your arm
oh I was performing at a festival like
two weeks ago and
I fell on a I was walking I finished my
whole set it was probably one of the
best sets of my my career it was in
Alabama and I was uh walking back
to the stage and there's just I was
giving out roses that's like the last
thing I do in my set and I slipped on a
piece of wood that was sticking up and
just face planted really hard and
everybody so it was probably the biggest
crowd I've had in a festival too is 15
000 people it was a giant uh
big video walls that are cameras always
on me so everybody saw it
and I I'm in the Kelsey Grammar who
Kelsey Grammer have you seen that fall
let me do a Kelsey Frazier he was an old
actor sitcom guy and he did a speech I
think it was a speech my favorite line
in it is like and he fell off this
gigantic stage and you see the cam you
just see him fall and then what's his
line he goes
dear God Jesus Dear God
it's embarrassing but so anyway I broke
both or I broke I broke this wrist and
this elbow here but my doctor just let
me take off the sling so I have to kind
of I kind of keep it like in this area
but I gotta like move a little bit to
kind of heal it and when you when you
fell was it the most embarrassing thing
well I felt dumb but I I knew everyone
was I didn't realize that there was the
video cameras filming me the whole show
I didn't know that I was like oh these
yeah 100 people saw me but now I was
like 15 000. wow uh I mean I got up
quick and I instantly knew that I
probably sprained my wrist uh but I was
like it's fine I've gotten hurt a lot
and I just kept giving out the Roses wow
particular one was broken in half but
bro you are so smooth look at this guy
let me see
but look look he gets up
yo what's up
not affected at all oh and my God so
cool dude so I thought I was look at
that crowd holy [__] pretty crazy crowd
oh my God the whole the whole thing was
it was wild but um that is pretty smooth
yes you bidened it bro
I think the opposite of bite oh yeah
yeah
wow so um and then after when you're
backstage you said to somebody like I
gotta go to the hospital well no I uh
just chilled out I thought I sprained my
wrist and it hurt then I woke up the
next morning and it was really hard to
like put my hoodie I thought I
dislocated my elbow because it was like
getting like stuck in like weird
positions wow weird but I was like oh
it's not gonna be that big of a deal and
then my manager and my mom both
convinced me to go to the hospital and
we went to MLK uh down in Inglewood
um wasn't the greatest
experience but
four or five hours I got I got my
results back there like yeah you broke
your elbow and your wrist oh my God and
uh sprained your wrist maybe being tall
are your bones weaker I don't I don't
know anything about doctors or the
biology or physiology but maybe I mean I
definitely fall farther and that's part
of why I broke it a lot far farther yeah
um and I also just with my you know
Hobbies I I get hurt a lot I mean well
touring I've grown a lot of Bones I used
to be a skier and got hurt a lot that
way
um but also I think mentally I'm a
little bit shorter than
like six eight six seven whatever it is
yeah
um
maybe more like a six four or six five
in my brain so then like there's a
couple inches that are not fully
oh your brain six four
a trip a little bit my brain's seven
foot three yeah I mean but yeah I'm five
four so you think a little shorter maybe
like I just maybe
you should think your height I I mean I
tried it's more just my my you know the
coordination is not I think a little bit
behind and I'm not trying to slam you
anything but um you're a thin guy right
but is you want your whole body thin
because you're
your eyebrows are thin my eyebrows are
thin it has good eyebrows no they're
great eyebrows I'm not saying that did I
just say
John did I say it was did I say did I
say it with bad eyebrows they're not
thin I just started thinking that I
started thinking I had like a condition
or something losing my eyebrows yeah
you're right I guess now and now when
I'm looking at it again it seems no all
right well oh my hair looks crazy guys
didn't tell me that I didn't know what
it was like it looks amazing I don't
know what yeah my bad I didn't know what
it was like before but I don't know how
you like it you know man well I mean
that's my yeah yeah that's my bad I
guess that's the research yeah but you
know yeah
what else is thin
um
the wrists we've talked about the udon
already yeah we don't have to get into
the thin thing because you know what I
read it wrong and now by looking at your
eyebrows they seem pretty normal to me
okay thank you and I apologize for that
attack good it's okay do you is there
anything about me that you would like to
um now that I'm thinking about uh do you
have eyebrows or what is going on
okay that's you know it just it comes
that's an attack but you know what I
could roll with the punches it kind of
looks like you you got Ash on there or
you had Ash Wednesday but you kind of
missed the forehead yes
and Pompeii when the [__] volcano
like you know Ash Wednesday when they
just put the little like Mark right here
why is Mark Wahlberg associated with
Ashley yeah yeah promotes it heavily oh
good for him yeah yeah you just got
ashed on your phone
is there really a mark there no no your
eyebrows I can't tell if it's hair or if
it's just a smudge
well that's [__] rude well I don't
know you asked that's [__] up I hadn't
really thought about it yeah yeah yeah I
mean I'm not a Harry whoa what are you
doing
oh yeah they're there maybe my
eyesight's also not great yeah let's not
you know what how about this you know I
started the eyebrow thing right and we
had an eyebrow War right and let's call
it truth wait I have a really good
microblading lady
what the [__] is that her name's like
Audrey glasses
good stuff like it's kind of like
tattooed but you tattoo the to make it
look like hair that's what my mom did oh
yeah but I've seen them like really
weird sometimes but not her hers is like
incredible maybe Trey do they wait do
they mic it's you go to a tattoo or can
a tattoo artist do it yeah but she's
specifically like a cosmetic like this
is microblading
wow it wasn't hers but and so but that's
permanent it's like two years I think
then it starts oh it's two years I think
as a I don't know could you do do men do
it and it looks all right uh I don't
know any men who've done it Matthew I
think but I think if you I'll do if you
do it you know what both should do
honest honestly dude you want to
microwave with me baby I want to get up
just straight like jet black yeah I'm
gonna do like a um you know you know I'm
a big Romulan fan you know I love Star
Trek you know I mean so I might do a
Romulan thing yeah what do you like the
you know like mine yeah like yours yeah
yeah yours you I was just I was looking
at everyone's eyebrows you got you got
nice ones yeah thank you
since we're talking about eyebrows what
do you think it is I like them I think
they're good they don't have like the
the shape that's what look that's what
it wants oh yeah what do you think okay
okay all right that'd be amazing yeah
I'm not gonna do the foreign
implants who knows you know what I mean
I wonder if you could do with your pubes
down there can does anybody micro
related that or no you want to add
tattoos on your well I don't like the
way it's shaped it's like shape very
John Holmes like just seven 70 is bushy
what's wrong with that
everyone has it right so I was thinking
of maybe doing maybe a wavy thing on the
top well you're just going to get a like
get it groomed that way oh that's nice
yeah yeah or maybe like do something
racist but no one will know like maybe a
little sausage taco or something
so you just want a swatsuka tattoo on
you what it'd be cool just to have it
down there and then when you're talking
to Jewish people you just you just know
it
might have to cut this we're going to
cut that out I don't know I'm just I'm
free thinking you know I mean so you
know I went to the eyebrow that didn't
work right and now I'm going to the
[__] uh swastika pube thing like
interesting social experiment if that's
what I'm saying you had that and then
when you hooked up with women for the
first time you're right yeah at complete
normal and you see if if they react at
all right that's right maybe maybe not
that maybe not that but something a
little bit like tame yeah what is the
better like maybe I know something yeah
less genocidey
um how about like a face like
so how about this your your face your
own Marjorie Taylor green okay oh like a
portrait of a portrait of her that's it
that's a that's a conversation starter
or Herschel Walker I don't know who that
is oh you don't know she's like a
republican like um I think she's a
congresswoman but she